is they switched the education system it
used to be just more standardized test
you have a test day every 3 months or
whatever it was and you're tested on the
material but they made the education
system more feminized um again men
operate on a hierarchy who was the
highest IQ women are more likely to
operate more egalitarian so everybody's
special and amazing and awesome so what
did they do they added
in participation trophies entally you
show up you get points just for showing
up the class being on time um they add
in all these papers these assignments
all of these little useless kind of
useless things that kind of prop up your
grade a little bit